good morning good afternoon and good
evening depending on
your time zone my name is lucia delta i
will be the session chair today
and today we'll have chang ho talk about
knowledge graph data modeling with
terminus db
and if you have any questions feel free
to raise them in the chat and i can
reach them out loud
take it away
yeah hello so um i'm check and um
so
like i said i am kind of quite happy to
have some interactivity so if you have
questions feel free to type in the chat
at any point if i see it i will try to
answer your questions
um so
this workshop it will be structured as
first of all there will be a lot of
information about data modeling i guess
um so if you're interested because
you're here um and then we'll have some
hand on
exercise that well i think since we are
now like remote so i would just do it
and then you can see how i do it and
then
um you can you know
follow along if you have any questions
again put it in the chat
um
yeah so
i guess this is how we would do it
so um in the middle there will be a
break a technical break for people to
you know get maybe get refreshed or um
just make sure your setup is okay so
there will be time for that but
uh it's always you know depends because
um
sometimes workshop goes very quickly
sometimes workshop goes slowly because
people ask questions so we'll see how
what we can do but um
anyway i'll point you to some kind of
more resources at the end anyway so you
could uh try it out yourself and
um you also know where to find me if you
have questions so uh let's get started
so
um i'm chuck i'm a developer relations
leader at terminusdb so terminusdb is
the
open source graph database that we will
be using today
so um again like emphasize on open
source so uh it's not you know something
that you have to pay for and it's all
you know it's
as long as you have docker you can get
the docker image and have it running so
um
so yeah it's just well my title is funny
it's just that i was a data scientist
like most of you but right now i'm just
kind of um
you know help developing the tool get
feedback from people um you know work
with the engineering team and then you
know also create tutorials so people can
start using the tool
um i love open source software um that's
why when i
first know about terminus db it's an
open source tool that's why i'm really
really happy to
join them and work with them um love
python like all of you
so also uh before i start there's this
discord link so this court is a
messenger thing kind of like slack so uh
we have a community there that everybody
can join now the team will be there as
well um so it's just like slack that you
can ask questions there um
also that's my twitter so feel free to
uh you know send me messages my inbox is
open but if you message me please kind
of let me know why you're messaging me
because uh you know sometimes more on
discord that i got people just say hi
and then i was like so okay what do you
want like
do i have to spend like five minutes to
talk to you to find out what do you want
so uh yeah it's just a little thing um
so in this workshop um you know that
like you will learn a lot of things so
um some of them is about
um how you can think
from
what you're used to for example
relational database how you can kind of
represent the data in a different way
is in the semantic knowledge roughly so
a lot of like fancy terms here but i'll
break it down for you in this um kind of
lecture or say or tutorial workshop
whatever um
and then um so what like how a semantic
knowledge graph is different from a
relational database
i would say the comparison is more like
3d and 2d but i'll give you more
detailed explanation in a sec
um so also we will learn how to um
construct a knowledge graph what's the
component of a knowledge graph and why
makes it so special
right um how to create it how to how to
model it we'll have hands-on exercise at
the end so which is great um i assume
everybody has some knowledge of python
to follow along at the exercise at the
end but even if you are not confident to
use python yet or
there's a little bit of hiccups because
of uh some python questions then um
don't worry uh you would at least be
able to follow along for the whole kind
of um you know
how to think about modeling in knowledge
graph when in the lecture part you will
be able to follow along it's just that
um for the hands-on exercise i would
assume some type of knowledge and if
you're struggling like i said i would
point you to some resources at the end
which you can take your time to follow
along afterwards and you know you can
always ask questions on discord as well
so um
yeah also terminusdv there's some
history about it um before it was just
purely everything need to
be modeled with um
more or less in rdf format which again
like new terms i will explain in a bit
but right now we have a new thing called
a document api which makes modeling much
easier um so all of these detail i would
i would just kind of explain later um so
one thing you have to notice is that
like we are using a new version so
um
this new document api only come in at
version 10. we have shown a few version
just to make sure that everybody knows
that it's different so um yeah document
api only available from version 10 so
make sure that the the image that you
get from terminusdb
on docker let's say it will be at least
version 10 or both uh python client
again version 10 or both they would work
together perfectly um
okay so
yeah and like i said anybody can just
you know follow the lecture it won't
assume that you know anything maybe i
would assume that you have seen some
kind of relationship relational database
or csv which i guess is quite popular if
you don't know what is the csv then ask
in the in the chat i am happy to give
you a brief explanation but i guess it's
quite common to people know what is the
csv um or what is the excel spreadsheet
um
and that's the only thing i assume that
you know um
and then when we go to the coding part
the hands-on exercise that would be
python codings i assume that you
you can do python coding
um just very basic knowledge uh if you
don't stand don't worry uh you can you
know python is very
friendly um i'm sure that you can find
resources to learn how to do like use
python and then you can come back to the
tutorial which
will be available online the code will
be available online all this stuff so
you can follow along
afterwards um so this is normally how i
would do it i know that we don't have
that much time today so um this is just
a brief idea so the the time
will be loosely um following along um i
think for hands-on training i'll just
cut this shorter
because if we are in the same room
together then i can just let you all
try uh yourself and if you have
questions i can come along you know
standing next to you and we'll figure it
out but unfortunately we have to do this
remotely so um
yeah i would just uh you know do a demo
like slowly so everybody can try
following along so but even if you
you know uh struggling or anything like
feel free to ask questions i'm happy to
like you know sometimes you only realize
that oh i have a question when you try
it right so feel free to ask a question
at any point
um so
yeah so that's basically it
um
so let me take a sip of coffee and then
i'll start explaining what is terminus
db what is semantic graph and all this
stuff okay
okay so what is terminus db so i've
mentioned many times already it's open
source graph database so two of the
most important aspect is open source
i've explained it's free it's open you
can see the source code it's not written
in python though it's written in
slip my tongue
written in prolog which is some of you
may heard about it so it's a very
interesting programming language it's
almost like a query
so everything is almost like a sql query
something it's very very interesting if
you're interested you know you can learn
it yourself i think the community is
very happy to teach people prologue if
you met someone who loved prologue
they'd be like oh my god join us you
know it's almost like cows they would be
like oh come on like i'll teach you for
a rock and stuff it's
lovely um so yeah like this reading
prologue and also rust so rust again is
uh is you know it's a diff language
different from python
um but yeah you can see the source code
if you're interested uh so we have
javascript client and the python client
they all both uh open source code is
hosted on github feel free to have a
look
um
so it's a knowledge graph database so um
i think today we're focusing on talking
about graph database
um how is it different from
a like sql based or relational database
right um and also because of that we can
um do revision control uh because
um the design of terms db is uh graph
based so it's
so if those of you who have used git
before if you poke around at like some
kind of operation and a lot of time you
come across an illustration that is very
graph like so
um with
you know with that design that terminus
db is graph based so it's it can do
revision control you can do things like
it so which is quite amazing i would say
um
so collaboration is very easy you can um
you know uh like if you have used it
before you know that
both of you can work on different things
and at the end you combine it together
or you can see what's the difference you
know and how you can you know um
you know roll back if someone made a
mistake or something like that so which
is great um
also manage access is working in
progress right now but
oh
so yeah we have already a develop a
version that
people can you know have a team and then
people
invite people to join your team and then
collaborate on the same database
um that we just did an internal
hackathon yesterday and then it's proven
working but we haven't
put it in production yet so um but
that's something that uh is going to be
uh available
so um it's quite cool
um
so
a semantic graph so semantic graph i
would say that why do we need that why
we we're happy with c co why do we have
to learn something new and you know put
data in this semantic graph structure
okay
why you're not happy with you know data
tables
so um
so i think uh for those of you who work
um
as a data scientist or who have been
working with data people you have heard
the term data lake quite a lot so
usually data lake
is um
kind of uh describing things like um
s3 buckets for example or google uh
google have similar i forgot the name
but like google have uh you know their
version of that as well so
what it is is that you just dump
everything right like a google drive is
kind of like that as well so you dump
everything in in this lake um so there's
lots of data they could be anything they
could be uh you know a file that is it
could be a flat file so it's kind of
like text it could be a json it could be
a csv uh it could be
some kind of um
some kind of any kind of binary
file and more complicated stuff a game
let's say um or video so um it's a big
it's just just something you can put it
there and you give back a link to access
the data
so um
yeah people are suggesting that oh yeah
that's slack channel and also there will
be people can share materials yes
definitely please go ahead to do it so
in this data lake all you have
is a link to get back your data
um there isn't much about it uh there is
an you know um
much thing you can do about it
so
um but
uh so that's that's the extreme end of
how you can store data without any
structure it's totally flexible you put
anything there
um versus uh a csv or let's say um let's
say google spreadsheet okay everybody
use google strategy so um
everything needs to be you know
put in a table format you know you have
columns you have rows
you may have an extra sheet if you want
to um but everything needs to be
flat so imagine if you have something
complex you know
for example um
we have a structure uh i'll show you
later like that as a structure of a
company someone's managing someone then
you have you know um you will have a
nested relation because
well
someone's managing this person and then
but this manager also have their own
properties right so
um
it's not as straightforward as
um you can
you know as
it is just for example a date of birth
it's just a date
a name is just a string so it's not like
uh you know
a person what so what is a person a
person what a person's name is is that
equal to a person no a person is more
than that they will have the age they
will have to let's say their picture or
their you know
when they join the company all this
stuff so um so it's complex some of the
objects in
in the world is complex and you can't
just describe it
like a string or like you know a number
something very plain um so you need this
kind of data lake with a structure so um
that's why we have a semantic graph then
that is very flexible you can describe
almost everything
but with a structure with some format
that is not just a link of something and
you don't know what this link represents
is it a picture is it a video is it a
csv you don't know
um
so i already explained open source
community driven so that's why we love
all of you please join our discord
and graph database it's very flexible
it's a little triple so we'll come
across triple in us in a bit so
everything is describing triples which
is very small thing but very powerful
thing um
and um so
the advantage of that is that you know
for example
uh so how we can kind of
um
not hacked but like how we can kind of
represent a person for example
in a relational database usually you
give them an id right you're giving them
an unique id and then you can kind of
you know maybe you can store everybody
in another
table uh or spreadsheet and then
that would have all the things
describing this person the name their
title that like where they leave
whatever whatever um and then you can
find this person by the id so there will
be a lot of joins a lot of aggregation
for example and
uh so for those of you who have used sql
you understand what i mean sql can be
very long to just do something very
simple
so yeah so that's that's why
um revision control already talked a
little bit about it so every time you
hear revision control you can think of
i'm just talking about git uh
the easiest to understand so you don't
have to you know
remember new terms it's just just like
but now just think it's equivalent to
git right um
you can do branching merging um rollback
reset
all this kind of stuff
um okay so
um new thing uh now we have uh so
before i describe that you know it's a
data lake with structure right so the
structure is provided by something
called schema so schema will describe
how the data should look like so you
know what to expect it's not like
finding
a needle in haystack is that is you know
you don't know what you're looking for
or what you're looking at if you're
given a link if you're given a link that
is where this
let's say person object is sitting
because you can always look at the
schema and see what a person object
should structure they should have a name
they should have a
title they should have age with this
stuff so then you know what you're
expecting um and then document api is
very good you would see it later um
iphone client so it's good for everybody
because we all love python
with python client it's just make
a lot of operation quite easy
so right now since i've been developed
it for
more than a year now so it's start from
very very basic that you it's just a
wrapper
wrapping the the api call you know that
normally you do it with for example
request all this and now it's wrapped in
a client's operation are more
straightforward and easy to understand
and then
later developed by more kind of a handy
tool there's a command line to it now
that you could easily
get your schema back uh you know you can
inspect a schema in python kind of
format you can put it back uh in the
database kind of easily so
all will come into pieces when i
demonstrate it um also there is um
so this this thing is a bit tricky i put
it here because it was a thing in the
past but right now we have temporary
take it down because we are we have the
new version right we have the document
api and we have to update this bit this
component the interactive graph
representation but it was something that
is loved by everybody in the past um
there's actually a
for those of you who know d3 that
actually is interactive graph so um if
you have used bouquet then you know like
it's kind of like okay interactive you
can zoom in zoom out you can move the
note around
or you can you know color code them and
so uh it's
um
it's rendered in javascript so it works
in jupyter notebook you can export it as
html file
but sadly this is temporary not
available because we have a lot to do
about this new version and then we would
get this up to date again and then put
it make it available again but if you
want to see the demonstration you may
have to see some of our older blocks and
then you'll see it in action
so um
terminus db is available on docker hub
for those of you who want to run
terminus db locally i would expect you
to have docker install on your computer
um
so once you have docker installed you
don't even need to
know how to use docker to use it um we
have a repo um i don't know whether i
can click on it right now yes okay we
just kind of bring it back here so uh
yeah
so uh here is our
bootstrap repo which um if you uh clone
this uh not clone like if you
now you can just like you know whatever
clone it locally like download it um
yeah clone it locally or download
whatever like whatever you like um then
you can just run this rip uh we have a
script that basically
um
will spin up the container automatically
so
you don't even need to
need to know how to use docker like okay
so
i i rarely use docker directly because i
am not in the depth of space
um but you know i have docker installed
so you can see here i have docker but uh
yeah i just use that uh bootstrap quite
often
um so yeah and i guess like for those of
you who
may be more experienced than you may
already have docker because it's such a
good tool um so
yeah two official clients that's working
right now python client and javascript
client
um we'll be focusing on python client
because i guess um for demographic more
people
would be familiar with python than
javascript um but that's also available
like if you um want to have you know
integration with some kind of web
application javascript client would be
useful um
yeah so
i think we had some point like someone
coming to us saying they are developing
a web application or website with ruby
on rails or something so they want a
a ruby kind of client and we say oh we
don't have but we can support you to do
that because we're open source and also
um
it's just uh you know we have api
available for any tool so you you can
if you want to you can definitely
develop your own client
um
so let's continue from here
okay so that's the overview of uh what
what are we using today so um then we'll
go to the modeling part um to explain
what is triple uh what is all these like
documents what is this thing that you
all talk about um but for that i would
need to have a few minutes to drink some
coffee uh it's also a good time now to
pop in any questions uh like you know
someone mentioned in chat we have a
slack channel
uh that's available so
um you can also
you know
yeah like put some questions there
as well um yeah installation i would uh
so yeah like
it's good that everybody is helping each
other but i will also give you more
information
later after the lecture so you can um
install it but right now i think you
already know that you need um docker
right so yeah
[Music]
right
okay
yeah in the past when i give the
workshop i talk too much and then i just
start coughing which is not good so
i'm trying to tell myself take breaks
doing some coffee okay
so knowledge craft data modeling
um
like i said the ferry free
uh
you know that you can think atom of a
knowledge graph is a triple so
uh the minimal unit would be a triple
here we have so
cool here i don't know where it came
from but
i hope you can still hear me okay right
so um
there is uh also how you can
converge like so
i think what we may want so what we'll
do today is to convert a um
a example relational database into a
graph database so uh also we have to
know what's the difference right so
let's we'll also cover that
so like um explaining what are these
terms objects document what are they um
are any other things that i have to know
um also properties so this bit is a bit
um
i'll give you more detail about what
what are properties in a knowledge graph
but um
so
yeah i think the most important thing is
to how to um represent data in a
knowledge graph right
how we can put
um how we can
use knowledge graph to describe anything
um
so today the information i gotta give
you um
so in theory you don't have to
understand all of them to be able to use
terms db thanks for our document api but
it's good to know this knowledge because
um when you talk to some kind of graph
enthusiast they will talk about rdf and
all this stuff which is you know quite
deep and then if you know some of these
basics you can
talk to them about it and it's easier to
communicate that way if you speak the
same language so
triple so knowledge graph sometimes
called semantic knowledge graph
they all kind of in the form match that
is called an rdf format so luckily i've
done my homework and the name is there
we
resource description framework so rdf so
i just say ldf most of the time but you
know i don't
really understand what r b and f
represent here you go
um
so the smallest component like i said is
a triple so um
so triple as the name suggested so it's
three things um
so
that would be um in technical term
subject predicate and object
so can think of um
well language is a bit more complicated
but if you think about it like for
example you teach a kid a new language
so it won't be very complicated or
you're learning a new language
you're not making a very complex
sentence you can make very basic
sentence and still kind of communicating
okay for example
um apple is read so this is how you can
teach a kid right like you know holding
an app for the apple is red so
um that's how you describe an apple with
three things so subject predicate object
so for example what i'm doing now is
chuck teaches a workshop
or you know animal lovers here uh cow
loves duck
so um
with just three things you can have
semantic which is meaning um so that's
how you can construct a very very
kindergarten level simple sentence that
a three-year-old could understand um
so
uh
can any one of you
yes someone already did
claudia prepares coffee oh and i love
the emoji as well great
so yeah if you have any example feel
free to put that in the the chat in soon
and then
yeah so
so we can have joy of
the triples i guess so
um for example uh if you're running out
of idea you can look at here that um
if you should so imagine this is
something in
a kid's storybook you can you know when
you're reading it with the kid
imagine what you do
so
um cow says mu
says quack
no cow has four legs
you know a cow is smiling
something like that right and then um so
this is all triple so with all these
triple you can describe this picture to
a kid
so that's why triple is very very small
very simple but very powerful because
that's all you need to describe the
world in theory
so triple yeah can link together to make
a complex
uh understanding
like the picture that i've just showed
you you can use these kind of children
like sentence to describe it to a kid
and they understand um
and then
you know this is all you need to
describe a picture right
um
so this is very very cool so this is the
building block of a cinematic graph just
triples a lot of them
um but we may come into a problem um
when we designed a more complex graph
that
is more powerful
imagine you have this picture
so this is our mask of cow duck so
counter is is this this this little
creature here
so
so how would you describe it right you
can say cow duck says
kyle says meow so oh
wait a second so which one is true there
is a contradiction here
and then you can you have to say oh cow
ducks is different from cow duck
so
whoa what's going on so here imagine we
have two universe um
so one so there's
like sci-fi movie now right it's a paleo
universe so in this universe uh caledon
says mu in this other universe covers
say smell
so um
why do we need that why is it useful
imagine um
git again right so github repo i think
some of you may have um you know github
account or have done something with
github
you know that people can make a fork
right so they can make so make a fork is
like making a copy of that ripple for
example pandas we all know pandas um i
can if i want to contribute to pandas i
can make a fork of pandas
you know maybe i would
do my changes whatever put it bug fixes
whatever put it in my version
and then send it send a p out right a
pull request and then ask like the the
the maintainer of panda saying like hey
i have these changed uh see if you like
my version
so
then at this time there's two versions
just like two cow ducks so
now it's like let's say a cow dog should
say meow instead of moon so this is a
bug fix
and then you are comparing to the main
branch which is the original pandas so
this is your pandas well
well this is a cow or duck this is not a
panda anyway i just find it funny um so
you're comparing these two
um
so then you have to make distinguish
between this one and this one right so
this is kind of a clone of it but it's
kind of different because i make some
changes to it
so that's uh
why why is go back okay so that's why we
need court
so
um quartz is
a triple with
well as you can imagine quartz is four
things right so is the triple added with
one
extra element that is um describing
um
what
universe it is in let's say uh we say
it's in a different graph
so
um
in this picture so this chaotic is let's
say is in the
main branch so it's in the main graph
and this codex is in the modified branch
which is modified graph
so
if you are using triple so then well
cardone says mu cardo says male they are
you know one of them can be true right
but if you're using quads so calor says
mu
in the main branch
caloric says meow in the modified branch
so the last thing in the what branch
would be the graph identifier
and that would make
um so you can compare them right now now
with these quads then you can kind of
compare two different versions
and it's useful when you think about
that if we want something like git then
this would be very useful because you
can compare the two versions
um you can also do cross references
so in case you have built a graph and
someone has bigger graph
if you want to cross reference then you
can do that so
all you need to worry is that every
element
or object or document
in your graph is unique they will have a
unique document id
your friend's graph may have another
document with the same id but
you can't tell right because you're only
governing your own document in your
graph you can make sure that the id are
unique but you can't make sure that the
document in your friend's graph is
unique come like
it's different from yours as well
so that's why you need this graph
identifier in case your friends graph
using the same id but that's in that
graph so it's different
okay so so far is that clear
it's coffee time for me again
okay
so um how can we put that into practice
now we understand um chord and um triple
so how can we actually put them together
to make a data model
so um what we used to know um
uh the relational database model which
also sequel database or something like
that
um
that
like i talked about before they are flat
they are tables so they have rows and
columns so everything is you know
every cell that if you have used excel
you know that you have different columns
and then columns and row would be the
kind of like geometric kind of uh you
you you you're gradient like yeah like
the x y axis right so yeah the cross and
then in the middle that's the last uh
element
all right so you have rows and columns
and some of the columns could be the key
so they kind of
you may need them because you have
multiple tables you may want to link
different things together
so that's how you can
cross-referencing
um
just how it works in relational database
models so
um
most of the time you can
extract them in csv
format so csv is comma separated values
so i assume that you know otherwise
i could also give you an example
um so
even if you for example your excel have
multiple spreadsheets you can have each
of them
each table as a separate csv you can
still
extract them as a csv
um
so the structure is very important so
each uh columns they need to be um
having a name you know a header will be
saying which column what they mean
um
also rows
so what does a row mean it could be a
person it could be a
in dress it could be
you know just a record of data a run of
one experiment a result of each test you
know
um
so a lot of join and aggregation is
involved like you know i talked about
earlier um if you want to
cross-reference
different things uh then you need a um
a you know to join the keys together
right
um so i don't yeah i guess like most of
you are familiar with this
um a knowledge graph which um
is different it consists of triple
and um we would use uh rdf like i said
or sometimes it's xml format so
well i think some of you may come across
xml if your open xml file is like um
it's like html
i don't know because when i was a kid i
like poking around website and all this
stuff i would you know look at the
source oh that's html so html is kind of
a special type of xml so that's why it's
um
yeah it's very very similar
um
ttl um so it's a
uh we call the tutorial files um
so it's another form it's kind of kind
of similar to ldf file um json ld for
match so json ld we use a lot in
terminus db so it's a json so i guess
you may know what is a json so it's
almost like a python dictionary
um
so it's nested so everything is nested
um you can have um
yeah so i i don't know like uh okay so
this is the full name of
of json md so yeah
most of the time when i say json for
match people know all of this but uh
yeah so this is javascript object
notation okay
uh so yeah so data is unstructured so
it's well structured in the sense that
you can
put for example in a json file you can
put
as much layer as you want you can a very
nested thing right so it's not that
structured you can
um you know
put this part out and then put another
dictionary or other json in so it could
be like json have a property that is
also another json that's like very very
complex it's not structured
um
so
um yeah so a triple you know the the the
um
the act of like the careful the
functionality of triple is to paint the
picture like we did in the cow and duck
use case
um
so always trip trip yeah i guess you
said is it always triple yes
uh label property graph
yeah so i'm making me focusing on
semantic graph right now so semantic
graph like a previous slide said that
it's a semantic triple
so um yeah so that applies to symmetric
graph so of course there's other
graph
format out there the other graph
database they may use different
kind of structured
different model but this is symmetric
graph model
mainly
so yeah
um so the good thing about that is that
um if you have a bunch of data that's
not well structured so a very simple
example
if your data let's say you are scraping
something from an api data so a lot of
apis they love giving you the the
response as a json right so if you
convert that into
let's say pandas data frame
a lot of times you will have a very ugly
data frame
because
um it does well you can use some uh some
methods in pandas to flatten it but
a lot of times it got flattened and it
may not be the way that you want it to
be flattened and sometimes you have to
flatten it multiple times because the
json is really nested
um then it will require a lot of skills
data you know data manipulation skills
to flatten everything to
make sure that is you know all the
columns are
looking beautifully um
but you know if um
if you have like this kind of
data from api if you can just use it as
is because it's nested and then
um you don't have to flatten it that
would be a great advantage because um
sometimes this nest structure
is easier to understand
um like i said for example a person they
may have um the age you know name title
these are well these are quite
straightforward right h is number
h is just a number um and then a title
and stuff with string but sometimes you
may have
uh the relationship between people so
maybe a person's spouse is another
person so
it's not something that you can simply
put it there
um
then sometimes this nested
structure could be
useful
um
also if you extract the knowledge so
this is more technical so if you want to
extract the knowledge you only need to
try
traverse the graph so you don't have to
um
let's say you would only
um so there's a let's say family tree so
if you want to find um my grandmother
you just need to transverse the graph
maybe find my parents um so you go to
either father mother and then find their
mother would be my grandma right
um so you just traverse the graph you
don't have to okay so i have to join
back my parents into
this table and then okay and then join
their parents into the table again so
you have to join it two times
so it could get complex very quickly
by this joining and aggregations
um
i think that for those who have some
kind of um you know have used sql
um for
you know for if you use sql so i was
using sql mainly when i was um data
scientist
at one job then
i'm i'm so good at sql at some point
that i'm like i can write a thousand
lines of sql and kind of get the job
done purely in sql right um i can find
some statistical kind of property of
this graph by just joining an
aggregation
but it's kind of
sometimes i've i found that it's like
unnecessarily complex
so
and what if i can just you know find the
answer by
by um some simple logic right
so um so this is the advantage of having
it
so
um
yeah so like i said if everything is
unstructured you have the flexibility of
do everything you want but there will be
a problem because if anybody can dump
anything in this database then you don't
know what they are
so that's why you need some kind of
governance you need some kind of
structure which is a schema
so
um
so yeah
well there's a little bit of funny thing
here just
what we used to call so in terms db when
we first assign it we have objects
documents and enums three things
um we try to follow what
the the naming usually would be for the
semantic
graph community but we decided that
actually that sometimes quite confusing
for developers or new users
get the slides yes i would at the end i
would give you a chance to get the slice
um but
yeah you you have you will get the slice
um
that's the short answer that question so
um so yeah we have uh this object
documents enum try to name it uh easy
for the semantic graph community to
understand but we realized that a lot of
potential users and developers they are
not semantic graph nerds they say um so
they may know a little bit about
schematic graph but not really totally
like
diving into it um so we want to make it
more kind of straightforward or
more easy to understand for developers
so we changed the naming a little bit so
it's a little bit confusing but
we will stick to the new naming which is
again it matches with
version 10 or above so um
so objects documents enum becomes
subdocuments documents and enums you'll
see why in a sec so
oops
i keep clicking the wrong
button it's okay so objects as a
document so um
so
um why we name it in subdoc two
subdocument because
um subdocuments and documents they
are both
well but they're both kind of objects
so you can think of them of both objects
but
the only difference a sub document and
document is is that the document is
supposed to be um a folder so it's a
collection of things that live inside a
document so here comes the sub in sub
documents it's um it's not a document by
itself it's just a collection of
properties within a document
that is bundled together because
um because sometimes convenience to do
things this way you want to
um for example a person's address so you
have the street name like the country
the town that they live in you want to
bundle these
three like things the street is all this
all these things that is address related
into
address caf category right there's a lot
of properties about person but these
properties are specifically for where
they live in let's say so you bundle
them into a address of document
so it's easier to understand um but
address itself doesn't mean a lot of
things because it only makes sense when
it's a property of a person because then
we know what this address is for alright
because otherwise it's just a address
it's like we don't know the meaning like
we don't know the
the the purpose of why we have that oh
because we want to know where a person
lives so
um so that's why uh is course of
document and calling it object is a bit
confusing because document is also
if you think about it a document is also
an object but you know so
anyway um so yeah
a document and as a document they are
both kind of
in a sense it's like an object in
object-oriented programming
or an instance if you think about python
so
um python instance they are all
objects which is a document or
sub-document
right
so um so yeah that's basically what i'm
saying it's written here um so yeah this
uh this
slice are designed as a kind of also
that was a lecture notes which i would
send
it to you all at the end but you have to
give me your email address and stuff but
we will come to that at the end so
um yeah this is the example i gave you
so address uh you have to you know it's
a collection of
property of a person that is
um that's all describing where this
person lives right so
you can you want to bundle them together
as a document
so document is
an object um so it's different because
uh it is something by itself
is mainly referenced by
so it doesn't need to necessarily need
to live within another document it could
be referenced by a
by an id so document always have an id
and they're always referencing um the id
for example
like i said if you have a company and
then uh so i have a manager so my
so
like if you look at my property i'll
have managed by another person so this
person will be referred as an id
sometimes it's useful because
what if i am
a one-man band i manage myself so the
manager i managed by myself then i have
to reference myself
if i can't reference myself with an id
then you can see the problem here
because then it's an endless loop right
i can't embed myself into myself
because then i will have to embed myself
into myself again and it creates an
endless loop which
is not desirable um but with a reference
then it's not a problem because i just
say like always
i'm you know managed by this person with
this id so it's kind of like um
a link to to link the two things
together
so
um
yeah so that's the main difference
between document and subdocuments
document it's always embedded within
another document now it also have an id
like technically but
most of the time it's not important
because
it's just live with within
its host
so you can think of it as just a folder
but a document is a thing of itself it
um is a reference if someone wants to
reference this
document they have to do it by an id to
refer to it
i click the wrong thing again okay
so um a document we're born with a few
properties um they are default um
so
you can see oh well it's confusing
what's going on uh the left hand side is
the old name that we use to uh
to kind of make it in line with the
semantic graph but uh
nowadays we use the name on the right
hand side because that's more intuitive
for developers and
people who code like you and me
so first thing you have an id uh it's a
unique identifier of an object or a
document
so it's like a key in sql
and then a name a name is a human
readable name and then um so it's more
flexible so
for this unique identifier then you know
like when you type in your email or
something you can't have space in it
you can't do crazy stuff
but with the name because it's human
readable so you can have space you can
capitalize non-capitalize you can put
emoji in it if you want to um because
python support emojis files
you can name stuff with an emoji if you
want to
um
description will be a longer description
um
it's
yeah like it's almost like a dog string
if you think about it you can have a
description
explaining what this is
um so these three are defaults so uh
any documents we're born with this free
property assuming that you have it um
but of course you can have other stuff
you can have
like a person's title person's age
business like more and more different
things
so
enum um for those of you who know sql
then
it's a enum uh it's the same enums um
but if you um
if you have never heard about it think
of it as a list of values so for example
when you filled in a farm
and you would have sometimes you have
options right like for example which
country you lived in then you have all
these countries listed then you have to
find your own country and then you know
you can't
well sometimes they will have others in
case they don't cover every single
country in the world but
but um
yeah but like you know it's a set of
values so it's not a free tax it's not
why you can put anything in it needs to
be either one of those
um
so these three are the three things that
would exist in a schema
in a
german db database
so um all these
so except enums or documents they will
have properties so properties is another
concept that you have to understand
um
with the document api properties is
just like an attribute um
in a um
in an object in python let's say but
um
but the semantic in schematic graph kind
of sense a property
is more complicated it will have a range
and a domain
so um a domain is that this means that
what this property belongs to
um so for example
a person has a name so the names domain
is the person
and the names range would be
what can be put in as a name so it would
be a string um
so the other example would be h so age
domain again a person
and then the range would be
a
integer
so
um so that's how you describe a property
in a semantic kind of sense
but like i said in the new kev document
api
terminus db version 10 or above
um you can just think of it as an
attribute um but
uh you don't have to worry about oh
domain and range it's a bit complicated
um well we changed that for you so you
don't have to think that way but just so
you know when you talk with um semantic
graph people then when they talk about
domain range of a property then you know
what's going on
um the properties there's two main types
so they're data type property or object
property
so data type property would be um
very
simple data type like string
integer um well i think i have a slice
talk about that yes data type will be
strings integer boolean
float and float is in python but it's
decimal in
our
in terms db um it could be something
more complicated and unsigned bytes um
in python like you you can you know
have daytime you know if you're in for
daytime so it can range from simple
things to complex things but uh they all
have something in common because they're
literal data types
they uh they're not
um an object of itself they're not
another document
it won't be expanding having more um
nester thing inside
it's just um a value and it depends on
what
what data type they are this value will
be interpreted in a different way
um
an object property which um
you know is you can think of it as a
link between two objects or two
documents in this case
so
they are um kind of
if you think in a document api
perspective you think that
um it's kind of embedding or
referencing another document inside it
so for example uh
uh my manager would be you know managed
by would be a um
object property
um also you know address you know
because this is a document but it's
still a an object property because it's
a subdocument address is a document so
yeah
yes um
yeah don't worry about the slice like i
said you would have it at the end
so
i wasn't dating a lot age graph so um
time for me to drink coffee otherwise
i'll start coughing
so here um we would do it by example so
we have an example of a data
a very simple database um that is in
tableau format and we will try to see
how we can put them
in a schema
first of all like i would say that when
you work with terminus db the first
thing is to think about how to
what is the schema because the schema is
governing how the data
will sit within a database right
so
um
always schema come first
make your life so much easier if you're
designing on a schema that doesn't
change a lot in the future
so
let's get started
this is
a company right um employee id for
people
um these are all like um
generated fake names but uh i'm
fascinated by how they all look
very real
um
and then they have uh the titles
um i just made them up right so they're
the only two teams in this company only
two managers
so you can make sense out of it i guess
all of you if you're trained
to be working with data then you know oh
manager destiny is the marketing manager
so managing darcy
so similar to this um
yeah so i i i never really think about
the agenda or anything i just generate a
bunch of names so um if you think that
this is a little bit biased then well
it's just coincidence i didn't really
think about gender or anything
just disclaimer um
so um
contact details of employees so um so
these are all i just addressed i don't
know why contact number when i use this
tool they give me uh
this doesn't look
like uk number but well whatever um but
the address do looks kind of uk postcode
and stuff which is uh yeah uh well i
live in the uk so this i'm more familiar
familiar with this so um yeah but anyway
um so these are all fabricated people's
address and their postcode and contact
number so
um so this company why they put
these two into two
tables is maybe because they don't want
everybody to have access to this um
personal details so maybe only a few
[Music]
people can have can see this right so
maybe most people can see uh who is the
manager of who but
um but most people
um can't see the these really personal
details here so
um
okay so this this i think this makes
sense i think this is uh what uh well
it's a very simplified version of um
what people you know uh
will to store the data in a company
right
so
now let's think about
what
documents we have so
um
what do you think when we start modeling
so what would be the documents
that we have here
so feel free to type in the
chat um
yeah
okay
so
employees yes that's correct you are
very smart um employees will be the
document so um
we would then
think about what properties these
employees would have so
this is the answer i don't want you to
um you know really like spend a few
minutes here well yeah i know all of you
are very smart but um
yeah uh so
you can
figure it out i'm sure i trust that you
can figure it out yourself so there'll
be um
name a string a title which is string
team
uh well we'll try to use enum here which
well you can totally do a string here
but um
i guess for demonstration purposes we
would use enum uh because we only have
two teams
um manager then
yeah so now we'll have to have uh
employee within it right so this this
will definitely be an object property um
contact number uh is well because of how
funny it looks i would just put a string
also uh if contact number is a number
then the first zero usually will be gone
which is not ideal so don't want that so
i'll just make it a strange i will um if
yeah if i'm doing it i'll make a string
which we will later so home address um
i would bundle everything
in an address object which is a sub
document
and then postcode
again it will be a just string so
um
so you may ask about oh what about the
id well um
in theory that is not needed because uh
terminusdb has the ability to generate
an id for you if you are not providing
one you can also tell homeless db what
uh
what logic it could use to generate an
id for example i can be like
oh i know everybody's name is kind of
unique uh i won't have another destiny
norris in well i don't think i'll hire
another destiny norris what are the
chances so you can say oh um please use
the name as uh
as the
literal
key right so
it will do it so you don't have to worry
too much about it uh in theory but
for demonstration purposes in this
tutorial i would
use the employee id
in the previous database to um
to manually create an id for it
just to be backward compatible let's
think about it this way
so um
for schema builder in terms db which
will be using the scaffolding tool in
the python client which uh
i'll be showing you there's also
a schema builder available in terminus x
which is the cloud version of terminusdb
so um
right now terminusx is in
public data so
you know in the future the plan is that
it will be a cloud service so it will be
a pay service but right now because it's
in public beta everybody can go and sign
up for free so um
so you there's an alternative for you
today um to if you don't want to if you
don't have docker if you don't want to
run it locally
you can go to our website and register
an account on terminusx
everything is very very similar it's
just that i'll show you what's the
difference but you can do the same thing
as i did and also the advantage would be
you would be able to use a graphical
tool a schema builder to do it
um
i will show you uh when i do the
demonstration so
now is the
pre-flight check so we have hit the one
one well i overrun a little bit
as about an hour since we started so i
will give everybody 15 minutes to get
ready um i also have to get ready for
the demo the demonstration as well
so um
so if you are used if you want to run
locally uh go to the bootstrap so it's
just github terminusdb strap
and then um
just you know
that provider that you have docker you
can do this um
and then the um
yeah so docker image you can get it from
the bootstrap and then uh python client
um
yeah yeah you can get copy yay so python
client um
you you just need to pick and store it
um the newest version will be available
but highly recommend to have a separate
uh private environment this is always a
good practice i tell people to do it
um so i can give you yeah 15 minutes so
i would uh post some link that would be
useful for you here in this chat also if
someone can relay it to slacks that
would be great
so um yeah i would just have a 15-minute
break and start again or maybe slightly
less than 15 minutes because i overrun
so maybe you will start at um
uh 15 after like quarter past i don't
know what time zone you are but quarter
past
um
yeah good so i would try to
see if i can oops sorry
how am i gonna do about this yeah i'll
give you some link uh to do so this is
bootstrap so people who are using docker
those of you
you can use this um otherwise you can
sign up for terminus x if you want to so
if you go to the website you can just
click on uh here
i'm on the top right hand side
yes
so that was and then um python client
also gives you the python client here
i'll try in
the installation yes here
so
here um so you see that i have a
terminal open i am in a new directory so
as you can see i'm in a well i'm in my
development environment which of course
have uh the python client installed
also i hope that
most of you either have your docker
running or you have a sign up for
terminus x so um oh yeah make sure you
have to verify your email before you
start using terminus x otherwise
you can start using terminus eggs so but
today i would demo using terminus x um
because you know it's easier to see
because there's the graphical interface
here i'm just going to give you a quick
tour like you have this to see all the
schema
um but these two are the old stuff that
i've done with other demos so let's
forget about that for a bit um
so we'll do something new um here so
i have the contact csv and employees.csv
which i have um
show you there
unfortunately i don't know how to give
you that actually
oh i have somewhere so i have to share
link which i forgot to share i'll do it
now in the chat um sorry about that um
so that should be the tutorial so
um
it's in here so yeah today's demo is
going to be a short version of all these
tutorials uh if you're interested um you
can you know follow along uh there's you
know a lot of things you can do so today
i'm just gonna maybe touch on
um a few things in here because of time
limitation
so i'll give you this link in the chat
give it to everybody
in the meeting
so you also find these two csv here so
if you want to follow along you can just
grab this to csv um
yeah
or if you like if you think that i'm
going too fast don't worry you can step
by step explanation is all here um so
it's good that you know if you're
struggling
don't panic you can always go to the
tutorial and follow along um also i've
made some recording about downloading
this as well they will be available soon
it's on youtube but i haven't linked
them yet so um but you will find them uh
in the future so
uh we have these two csv uh which is
exactly what the thing that i've showed
you um but i can also show you here
because it's github so yeah
exactly the same thing that i'll show
you in slice
um here yeah okay
so
um but before we do anything we have to
start the project so
once you have the python client read
installed so you can use the terminus db
command so i'll just show you a badge
yup
my typing is horrible especially when
i'm demonstrating stuff i also have
typos and stuff so
feel free to shout at me if i type
something wrong and i didn't realize
so
there are a lot of commands that's
available so
it's a very handy tool if you're using
it in junction with timeless db
for those of you who
decide to use terminus x you can always
use the the graph interface here to do
stuff but
personally i really like using the
command line interface here so
um let's start the project so that's the
first first thing you have to do because
it need to connect to
the determinist right so
start project
so you we ask questions here so you have
to enter project name so
i would do a correct demo
workshop
okay
this is my chosen name feel free to
choose whatever you like
and then you'll be asked an endpoint
location so here um if you are using
docker um you're running locally you can
just press enter here which that's the
end of
this journey uh to start the project
then you're all done but if you're using
terminus x like i do
um you have to do a little bit extra
more which is go to your profile and
then you will see that you have given
all this information how to set it up
with python which is very handy so the
end point is actually this one so yours
will be different you just need to copy
it
and then paste it here
so and then you would be asked a team
um so my team is here
so everything can be found in this
dashboard so
right uh am i using a jwt locked in uh
you will have to say yes if you are
using terminus x
and then do you want to set up the token
so i haven't set it up yet so um
actually i have set it up before so i
can say no here but for demonstration
purposes i will say yes and set it up
again just for you
okay so i have to get a token so here um
i would have to say you know maybe pi
data global
demo something like that uh to generate
a new token
then you would be given the token which
is a super long string then you just
need to click the little button to copy
it and then paste it here uh it won't
show it here when you paste it because
it's a secret it's where you're not
supposed to show to the world so it
won't show in the screen
so
now it says that um the conflict json
and schema.pi is created
so now let me clear the screen
and show it to you so now we have the
convict json and schema.pi so
config.json is um is the json store or
your configuration to connect to um
to to your terms db or terminus x
um schema.pipe right now is a um demo so
if i open it with my um trusted
atom which is my uh ide of choice you
can use whatever oh someone asked a
question any plan to allow oh loud noise
running times
oh sudo
problem okay yeah we have um yeah we
have been uh trying to
see what setting is the best for people
so yeah i would uh relate your your
questions to the team because i'm not in
charge of that part but i can tell them
that actually people
want to use it without pseudo so um i
would talk to them about it very good
very good question um
yeah yeah so right now yeah right now
it's uh it's not but i would i would
talk to them and see like
you know what's going on there um so
yeah very good um
okay so
so this is just a json file holding all
the connection and schema.pi you see
this is just an example
so um yeah so it's just an example of
what you can do with schematic pi you
can do your modeling here
which uh in terminus x you can always do
a um you can always use the uh gui
interface but i personally i prefer
python so
um so here you can just um
you know see this example and then
change it to whatever your heart um
you know
uh what's what how do people say what
you want what you uh your heart
delights you know yeah whatever you want
so um
so also you can see a lot of dog string
here um that's the advantage of um doing
it in python because you can um document
everything all this will also be um
uh you know pushed to the back end push
to terminal db so it will be stalled um
in terms db so um which is good it will
preserve uh okay so
i am going to cheat a little bit because
of this short demo i'll try to leave
some time at the end so people can ask
questions i can show you this like how
to get slides and all the stuff um so i
got to cheat a little bit by copying
what i already built so this is what i
already built um for this uh awesome
startup that i call it um so i just copy
and paste this and i'll explain it later
so
we don't need the employee from csv for
now so let's delete it and save okay so
um this is exactly what we have uh you
know what we've talked about in the
slides um i will have employees as a
document as you can see um
address of the employees would be an
address which is this one
um so this is a sub document
so to declare as a document you just
have to make as a document equals to
something it doesn't really matter what
it is but
um you need to have a subdocument flag
here
um
so the address will have all these
properties that's related to an address
the postcode the street street number in
town um you can also add docstrain to
describe what these are in case this is
not clear to people
um
team would be enum
um so you have a marketing and i.t
um
yeah so
but all these details if you follow the
example then the example will give you a
more detailed explanation of this um so
uh
yeah it's a little bit oh wow a lot of
information overload for now but if you
are really using it then you can just
look at the example schema then you you
would see more like kind of what how to
create enum and other stuff
um
so we have the address for employee
contact number will be a string
manager would be an employee i make it
optional because the managers don't have
manager like destiny is the manager so
she won't have a manager
name is a string team would be a enum
team so all these uh well
i put in quotation in case i declare it
afterwards then
otherwise python won't like it they will
say python would be like oh team is not
defined or something like that so
put them in quotation so these are all
kind of um
type hinting in python so
uh in case you haven't used taiping tank
before uh there's a lot of resources
online talking about that so um you can
also learn a little bit about that um
so this is basically how it works okay
um
you'll get used to it very quickly
because this is very very python
okay so this is the schema that we have
done um
so we know that this is going to be like
this so let's go back to the terminal
so what we will do now is to commit our
schema so
just type commit i can also add a
message just like this is very similar
to those of you who use git rather this
sounds familiar so
it is um so
it will be
creating
schema something like that this is just
whatever message you like that you will
understand in the future
yes type hinting oh someone already give
you uh some resources which is great uh
yeah it's amazing that we are
self-helping
like we are helping each other here so
uh yeah if someone can relate that to
slack that's
good because someone may want to see it
in the future
okay so let's do this and then
we have created the database because we
haven't connect to terminus x in my case
yet so you can't see it in my dashboard
but now you can see it if you refresh
um and then it will create a database
and then create a schema so
let's see
here in my dashboard if i now refresh
you will see i have three database here
now before it's two so if you go to demo
workshop which is a new one
you look at the schema so this is what
we have built in python um
so you can again you can modify and
change it um here with this gui
interface if you're using terminus x but
uh well for me i i prefer python anyway
so
so some documents are green
so address is green and then employee
here right
so enum so this is oh very very clear to
illustrate that's why i want to
uh yeah that's why i want to show this
um in terminus x but it's perfectly fine
if you do it in terms db because most of
the stuff i do it you know in this gui
interface anyway
in this cri interface anyway so
our next step is to uh insert the data
so
again i gotta do uh what i'm very good
at which is cheating
so
here um i would go to um
my already so this is this is what i
just shared with you uh in the tutorial
github repo
so you will find the insert date of the
pie so this is what i've written
to insert data with a python script
i just read the csv
you can also use
pandas to read in the csv if that's more
convenient for you um i built a tutorial
using just the csv
library because um not all of you will
have pandas but i assume because you're
you know uh from you're attending pi
data global i assume that you love
pandas and you have pandas so um you can
use pandas it's it's okay
and then you just um you know
for this csv is a little bit tricky
because like then you have to you know
create some dictionaries and store stuff
there
with the employee id as the key and then
uh so yeah i i store them
here
and then so the id will be the key of
the dictionary and then i construct the
address so this address object i want to
highlight this a little bit so this
address object is just import from the
schema okay so the advantage of having
this schema the pi here because they are
declared as a python class
you can actually import them
to use so i will just copy this so it's
easier i don't have to switch between
these two so i would call this insert
data dot pi
or just
create this file first so
um
yeah so uh
so you can just use it as a class in
python and then create an instance which
is
you know a document in pi in python so
um it's very you know uh
i i i quite like it uh i think it could
be
marie has a question she says yes i'm
using terminus db and my input
x363 it shows a coming soon page
yes
um
so i'm using terminus x so terminus x is
a um to come with a dashboard okay so
you can
do this
exactly look like what i'm doing but if
you're running it locally um it doesn't
come with a dashboard yet
okay so that's why i said that you can
totally just follow with this kind of
command line interface it works just
fine it's just that you won't have the
visualization here like like i'm doing
i'm using terminus x because then i can
visualize and show it to you
but
if you
uh running it locally
you don't have the visualization yet so
you
you can only follow here but there's
some other commands that let you uh have
a look at what your schema is so if you
type terminusdb um or docs
schema
then you would see
the schema
as a json
coming back
or if you want to see what your schema
has you can just hop over to
schema.pi it should be you know a
representation of this but if you want
to verify that it's in the backend you
can just type
terminusdb or docs schema
this will show you that oh this is you
know what it looks like in the back end
so it's just a a little bit you know
nicer to have a visualization in
terminus x um otherwise it's just
working the same
okay
so yeah coming soon that's exactly what
uh what is supposed to be right now
because the dashboard is not available
on uh for the local version yet it will
be uh we have plans for that but uh not
right now
okay
so insert data again coming back here um
so this is just like data managing
um
you know if you feel more comfortable
using pandas you spend the uh it's just
that i will have to create a lot of
address object how to hold the addresses
so all these attributes so you can just
um assign it like this okay
um so employees similar thing i have to
create employee object
now they have the id that i said that i
would construct them manually which i
did it here
um so i have uh you know the employee id
would be the first
so yeah it's my pandas then you can see
what it is but like now it's just oh
it's the first thing in the row which is
the id um
i just um so this is uh how a
id would be like
so you need to be the type of the object
and then slash and then whatever
identifier you use
um so i construct it manually because
it's
clearer in the tutorial so you know what
it is also backward compatible so you
can compare it back to the csv um also
um yeah right now the auto generator id
does not work so seamlessly between the
python client and the back end uh we
have plans to make it more seamless but
it's not there yet so um so manually
constructing it is my favorite way to do
it for now
um
and then also there's a little little uh
detail here that um the managers uh i
store the
mapping between the employee and the
manager with the id
separately because
the problem could be the
um
my manager may not be created as an
object yet because
that's the limitation of a csv
everything needs to be done in sequence
so
my manager could be not be created yet
so um i just so that's why i just store
the mapping for now and once all the
employees are created so i store them
all in the dictionary
then i can so it's an employee
dictionary so after i store them all
then i can
link my manager to my property
okay
um so this one i need to change it
because i'm
using terminus x so what i got to do i
got to copy
my thing in the
config.json
to change it up so i'm using this so i
am so i am using this following
and i'm not using this so um demo
workshop yes
my team is
terminal tv community
okay so i'm using this
and then um so if you're using locally
just you know use this make sure you
change the name of the db to the thing
that you want you set up before
um and then the client okay the client
is the
is just
an object in a python client when you
create it you need to put an endpoint
here
and then you use connect to
basically log in so also tell the client
which database you want to connect to
if you're using it locally
the login is very simple you don't have
to put anything you just need to say
what db you're using
and then you can do the client insert
document
so i have every
employee object store in employee
dictionary right so they will all be the
values
so i make so i call all the values and
then make them into a list
because this need to be a list
and then i have a commit message so i
think for employees so this one
hopefully should work so let's try
um
okay so no warning which is a good sign
i always say
so
let's have a look at the dashboard to
see if we have anything so
okay so
go to demo workshop and then look at the
document so we have four employees
here
right so this is the gui how it looks
like you can see everything in a table
but otherwise if you are using a local
version you can also verify
that you have other stuff
by using all docs
like this
and it should come back in the json
format so
yeah now you have
done it
so yeah this is the little demo that i
show you so if you're interested to
learn more
again the
tutorial is available there's six
lessons it's going to be fun to play
along
um
uh if you found any bugs in it please
report it because um i have just
finished writing them i i have already
been debugging by trying it many many
times but someone always finds something
you know also um so yeah if you find any
problems please uh please you know um
open an issue or pull requests you're
very welcome to do that
um yeah so i think that's the demo
so let's go back to the slice i have a
few things at the end for you
so let's go
um okay we've done this so
um terminus x i've showed you so this is
what also this is not very
good so that all the texts are a bit
funny oh i think i capture a picture
that's why but um yeah so terminus x
i've just showed you uh the main
difference right now is that
it's well it's hosts on cloud so you
don't have to get the docker image also
it got some kind of visualization that
is available to you that's not available
in the local version yet
um so and now it's in public beta so
everybody can sign up for free um but
it's a cloud service so of course you
know um cloud service normally would
cost something um so
so it's normally a pay service but right
now you can sign up for free so you're
encouraged to do so as well um
so
to sum up so in this workshop we have
learned a lot of things um so there's a
hour-long lecture telling you about like
you know um what is knowledge graph what
is the semantic knowledge graph what's
the building block of a semantic
knowledge graph what's the difference
between a knowledge graph and a sql
database um and then we try to have a
little example of thinking how to
remodel some kind of csvs into um voa
schema in the knowledge in terms db
um so
uh i've showed you a little bit of um
how you know it can be done with
the python client with a few commands
with uh time scripts uh
also um
you know
feel free to explore the tutorial
yourself if you want to
um
so uh yeah if you want to learn more so
this is kind of um a a kind of a trial
of running workshops like this kind of
formats it's more like
um a lot of you know information based
because like i have done a lot of
tutorial in the past but this this one i
think is the one that have a lot of
information lots of knowledge
for knowledge graph so um uh in the
future we may um kind of publish a
course uh we actually because part of my
job is to educate people right educated
developers so uh that's something that i
really want to do um but uh we are right
now as a trial we run all these
workshops at different conferences so uh
your feedback is very very welcome so um
these are all like how you can contact
with terminus tv and you know find us
and you know get in touch ask us
questions in the future um
so uh yeah your opinion is highly highly
um valued so i have this form which um
so if you don't want to give me any
opinion or you're busy that's fine i
understand everybody's busy you can just
click on this link and um you know i can
show you the form so it's just a quick
form so you can the bare minimum is just
tell me um your name and then your email
address and then just a few kind of
things do you want to be contacted and
then what i'll do is that i will give
you a batch um a batch that you nowadays
you see everybody's doing it right um
the link yes sure um
so yeah everybody is um
copying address so yes everybody is uh
sharing batches nowadays on linkedin so
um i'll give you a badge um actually we
pay for this service to be able to issue
badges so i'm gonna give out as much as
possible so it's kind of like a online
swag i can give you a batch that you can
share on linkedin saying that you know
how to
mod my model graph um data which is
great um
also i would uh share the slides with
those of you who um who sign up i'll
send you an email
personally um as well because this uh
this pdf is quite wordy it's quite you
know uh heavy so i don't know whether i
can um so canva i can't just i think i
have to export as pdf so i would i
prefer to send it to you by email um so
yeah just just fill in the form i'll
send you the email after maybe a few
days i'll open this for a little bit
um i'll open this form for maybe um
a week or so so be patient i will send
you the the um i would give you the
badge also send you the the slice uh
after because
i know that it's recorded i don't know
whether it would be yeah maybe i would
pay a little bit to watch online
next question is it workshop
1002 or 10 oh sorry that's wrong why is
it wrong sorry sorry that's that's wrong
ignore that one
i don't know how to delete it but
i don't know either
yeah it's uh sorry it's center g8
yeah it should be uh
10 28 yes
yes someone already fixed it thank you
i don't know why it's like so weird i
think i thought i've changed it um
yeah so okay let me give that a try and
make sure that works because you know
huh okay
yeah
it should work so um
yeah okay so
um
yeah why is it different ah okay so
huh strange
um
anyway yeah the use the 10 to h1 please
i think that one is the right one
um yeah so uh
and then of course you're welcome to
give us feedback i i really i will look
at them so please
um
yeah what else i think that's it uh ask
questions um
and
run python
ah
there is a new question saying yes
or you want to show me now is fine uh
but i think that in slacks maybe you
won't feel the pressure of showing it
live
um
yeah i'll be every on slack for during
the conference time
so
yeah feel free to ask questions
um
yeah also tomorrow i think i have a talk
uh
more about like related stuff as well so
you're welcome uh integration of aws um
not sure uh
the best is to ask the team uh yeah
aws i think we don't have that
uh in mind but because we have all the
clients available so
i think it's not too difficult to build
something to work with aws
uh because we have the python client
like if you have some services that you
know run python
scripts that's very very easy to work
together for the best i can imagine
but um so i don't totally understand
like what integration mean in your
question um so
uh but we're happy happy to chat about
it uh if you if you come and join our
discord or us team or you know or we can
even talk further if you uh contact me
um person like you know directly so
um yeah
we have
some more time yes uh
okay yeah that's fine um
if you can just give me as much detail
as possible um on slack i will try to um
understand what's wrong
um sometimes it's just that it could be
you know um
there may be something happening in the
in the in the schema maybe i i don't
know
marketing
yeah
so i for for what you showed me the
attribute error marketing it it's
probably something wrong with the schema
i guess i can imagine so
but yeah if you
you share to me i'm happy to have a look
also um
you may want to try like uh start over
step by step with this because this will
provide you more detail about like
what's going on and stuff so
um
yeah
um
another question from kotatrina or sure
in terms of performance inside is it
better than a relational database
yes for performance so
um well
i kind of well i
so i think the back-end team will give
you a better explanation but what from
what i've heard over the years of what
they're talking about because we have a
store that's filled with rust
so it's very efficient um also things
are stored in layers
so when you make a query you um there's
a way of like how they you know they
optimize
so it's very very complicated the
backend team can give you more
information so um there's
a
way of like
we will have new things coming in right
so each commit it will be layers on top
of each other normally when you query
stuff you would traverse the graph and
find the answer but there is some kind
of magic that they do i don't understand
that like that you can optimize it you
know maybe you can create kind of some
kind of a shortcut uh in some layers
that you can
query it quicker so um yeah so storage
wise is very efficient because it's in
rust is really compact
and for the query you can optimize it to
make it quick but if you're really
interested
you know join the discord and talk to
the back-end team they can give you a
better explanation of everything they're
very passionate about making it
um as efficient as possible of course
because um
you know it's something that we are not
you know doing for fun
it's a product that we want to make sure
that it's uh useful for people so
yeah i hope to answer the question i
don't have too much information to
provide but yeah
thank you very much check um
by the way check is a python software
foundation fellow since 2021 so
congratulations for that
and she has a python podcast called mid
meat pie
she also has a follow-up talk tomorrow
at 11 30 a.m utc
uh in the talk one track on talking
specifically about turning those lovely
python
lovely timeless data frames that a lot
of us use into semantic knowledge graphs
so feel free to check that one out this
way
thank you very much check and you can
reach her as well
on our slack channel and hopefully and
gather yourself
thank you all have a wonderful morning
afternoon or evening depending on your
time
yeah thank you so much